So that's one, but another thing
we can do with classes.
Not just collect functions in there, but you can even collect variables inside
them. So what are some variables that
can be we can associate with with a car
so it's speed.
It's color.
It's a brand.
Could be a Toyota.
Etc right
Now we said that we've put functions started class
we call it methods. We don't we don't call them functions anymore. And when
you put variables inside the class again, we don't call them
variables anymore. What do we call a variables? We call them?
on the properties
Okay.
now
there is a little more to the current classes than just.
declaring methods and properties
we have
something called the dunder Reddit method or the initialization method
to Constructor function.
There are access modifiers.
I want we won't get into that right now. But and also
with these parentheses, why do we have these parentheses when
you have a parentheses in a function?
When you have a parentheses, this is where you
can Define your parameters.
So let's say you have another function.
Okay, so that's a that function already exists. So I have
to create another function.
at numbers
and by the way, this is called camelcase notation.
But in Python the snake notation
is more popular. So snake notation is
when you separate two words.
with an underscore
Nami conventions are also covered in tutorial by the way.
So let's say this function if you remember we said that a function is something
to what you pass.
An input it does some internal process and gives
you an output.
Okay.
So this will take two inputs now may not
be.
and it will simply
Return the result of this sum so we have Nom a plus.
number B
the very simple function
what do we call the
what do we call these these have special names?
I used and the non.
Programming terminology input but we don't call these input. There's another
name for it.
They call parameters.
so quick definition
a function parameter
And argument, they're not the same thing. Unfortunately, sometimes they use interchangeably.
Okay.
a parameter
or argument rather argument is the input of a function.
So if the argument is the input of a function, that was a parameter, the parameter
is the placeholder.
for an argument
Okay.
So these are the parameters.
they're like variables that belong to a function and
You can.
have infinite
Arguments for any particular parameter, so
what do I mean by this?
So this function has only two parameters but each parameter can
take on infinitely many argument. So this could be
100.
200 or 2000 or 500 whatever
it can be anything.
Okay, but it's important for us to distinguish.
parameters from arguments when you create a function
using the Define keyword and naming the
function and
putting the parentheses. This is called declaring a function.
But after you declare the function you want to call it.
Okay.
When you call the function, however, we no longer call these parameters we call
these arguments.
Okay.
What does this have to do with classes? Well, if
you notice classes also have parentheses, but
they don't take arguments.
at least not
through the
well, actually they do but you don't Define the
parameter here.
So a class will take an argument like a function but
not to the parameters not through the parenthesis rather the
parameters go somewhere else.
Rather the parentheses are optional and you only use them
if this class is based on another class.
Okay.
Once again in the tutorial I go into more details on classes.
So for example if car which is an abstract
idea, it is some sort of
vehicle
that has wheels some doors and it
and it's motor transportation is the road okay, but
a class which is an abstract idea is
itself.
a specific type
Of an abstract idea like a vehicle.
Okay, in other words if this class is based on another class.
Then that's when you would bring in the parentheses. Otherwise, you don't even
need them there.